planète étant le grand jour est arrivé
les amis super qu'est ce qu'on regarde
père je ne crois pas que ce soit pour
toi
il m'arrive de ne pas avoir peur très
bien c'est parti c'est pas du tout et
j'adore c'est pas vrai au bout de deux
coups un téléchargement c'est trop
triste c'est reparti qui es-tu je suis
maintenant c'est pas nous qui parle
personne qu'est ce que c'est j'ai été
formé avec seule chose
je n'ai aucune cause à défendre ouah
qu'est ce que ces grands quoi la plage
alors là c'est trop stressant
briand ne nous arrêterons
j'achèverai qu'est ce que c'est que ce
truc c'est que vous avez commis
on raconte toutes sortes d'histoires
c'est vrai
on a envie d'être amie avec tout est
vrai
ok je commence à avoir les chocottes
j'ai fait c'est beau mais elle est
plutôt cool merci j'avais déjà remarqué
le côté obscur
c'est comme une montagne russe
d'émotions que tu veilles
on dirait que ça va chauffer
il existe
la forme
est à peine
cossette
doucement
coucou as lattes envahir la piste des
vols vers les étoiles ping-pong bieber
c'est un peu trop stimulant pour moi un
square décembre on va être obligés
d'attendre ce sera l'eau